I'm saving hamburger I'm an
anesthesiologist at Mount Sinai this New
York anesthesiologist recovered from
Kovac 19 a month ago now doctors Evy
hamburger is among an important group of
frontline medical workers who hope
they're immune from reinfection the
blood plasma he's donating is also being
studied to treat patients so if we give
these this plasma to someone who is
acutely infected with coronavirus the
antibodies that are in the plasma for me
can hopefully start attacking the virus
healthcare workers are a significant
portion of confirmed kovat 19 infections
in the US the federal government reports
more than 9,000 doctors and nurses are
among those who tested positive and the
number is likely an under estimate given
occupation information was missing from
80% of those tracked cases they are
folks that you know by by default they
take on risk they know that when they go
into healthcare right so they don't run
away from the fire they go to this yeah
sorry that this is actually bringing in
one of our ventilators dr. hamburgers
now a member of his hospital's kovat
rapid response team performing
intubations on critically ill patients
this is the procedure that is one of the
scarier procedures in the coronavirus
era because this is when the virus can
be aerosolized he's volunteered to spare
co-workers who've not been infected but
the w-h-o says reinfection cannot be
ruled out through antibody tests alone
the question of potential immunity needs
more study meanwhile in Maryland a
parade of police cars have come to say
thank you to hospital workers soon it
will be back inside to waiting patients
and a virus we still have a lot to learn
about Eddie Joe Castro al Jazeera Silver
Spring Maryland